NEW REPORTING FROM "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" ON A HIGH PRICED GAMBLE
FROM THE NATIONAL REPUBLIC
SENATORIAL COMMITTEE TO SPEND
BIG ON DIGITAL OUTREACH AND
OTHER TACTICS, A GAMBLE THAT
ACCORDING TO THE "TIMES" HAS NOT
PAID OFF.
LISTEN TO THIS, BY THE END OF
JULY THE COMMITTEE HAD COLLECT
ADD RECORD $181 MILLION BUT HAD
ALREADY SPENT MORE THAN 95% OF
WHAT IT HAD BROUGHT IN.
THE REPUBLICAN GROUP ENTERED
AUGUST WITH JUST $23 MILLION ON
HAND, LESS THAN HALF OF WHAT THE
SENATE DEMOCRATIC COMMITTEE HAD
AHEAD OF THE FINAL SENTENCE
PHASE OF THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE REPORTER
BEHIND THAT ARTICLE, NATIONAL
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" SHANE GOLDMACHER.
THIS IS THE COMMITTEE OF THE
SENATE HEADED BY SENATOR RICK
SCOTT, THEY RAISE MONEY TO WIN
ELECTIONS FOR REPUBLICANS
RUNNING FOR SENATE AND THEY
DON'T HAVE AS MUCH MONEY AS THEY
THOUGHT THEY WOULD HAVE NOW.
>> THIS IS THE EXCLUSIVE PURPOSE
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
IT EXISTS TO ELECT A REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY IN THE SENATE.
WHAT WAS SO INTERESTING IS LAST
YEAR THEY WERE ANNOUNCING MONTH
AFTER MONTH THEY WERE BREAKING
EVERY RECORD, BRINGING IN MORE
MONEY THAN THEY EVER HAD DONE
BEFORE, YET NOW THEY HAVE MUCH
LESS THAN THE DEMOCRATS AND THEY
HAVE EVEN SPENT LESS ON ADS THAN
THE SAME COMMITTEE DID TWO YEARS
EARLIER.
SO I TRY TO SET OUT TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION HOW DOES THAT COME
ABOUT?
HOW DO YOU RAISE MORE THAN EVER
BEFORE AND SOMEHOW HAVE LESS?
>> AND THE ANSWER IS.
>> THE ANSWER IS THEY TRIED TO
INVEST IN A HUGE DIGITAL
PROGRAM.
THEY THOUGHTS WE'RE GOING TO
SPEND TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON GOOGLE AND FACEBOOK
ADS, GET PEOPLE TO CLICK, GIVE
YOU ARE YOUR NAME, EMAIL
ADDRESS, CELLPHONE NUMBER AND WE
WILL HIT YOU UP FOR MONEY.
THEY DID RAISE MORE MONEY BUT
THE PROBLEM IS IT COST THEM MORE
THAN THEY BROUGHT IN.
>> IT COSTS MONEY A LOT OF TIMES
TO RAISE MONEY AND THEY'RE NOT
SEEING THE RETURN ON THE
INVESTMENT.
LET ME JUST READ THE STATEMENT
HERE BECAUSE THEY SAY THEY ARE
DOING WHAT YOU CLAIM THEY SAID
THEY WERE GOING TO DO, IT'S BEEN
OUR PLAN ALL ALONG TO SPEND
EARLY ON AND TO GROW THE HOUSE
FILE WHICH IS PAYING DIVIDENDS
NOW AND WILL CONTINUE TO IN THE
FUTURE.
WE MADE THE INVESTMENT, WE'RE
GLAD WE DID, IT WILL BENEFIT THE
NRSC AND THE PARTY AS A WHOLE
FOR CYCLES TO COME, BUT NOT NOW.
>> LOOK, IT'S PRETTY UNUSUAL TO
SAY WE'VE MADE THIS INVESTMENT,
IT MAY NOT BE HELPING NOW BUT
IT'S GOING TO HELP OVER THE LONG
TERM.
AND THEY MIGHT BE RIGHT.
MAYBE YEARS FROM NOW THIS COULD
BENEFIT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY BUT
RIGHT NOW IT DOESN'T.
AND ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS THAT
THESE LISTS, THE EMAILS AND
PHONE NUMBERS THEY'VE VACUUMED
UP, THE TACTICS THEY WERE USING,
THE TACTICS THEY USED TO RAISE
THE MONEY FROM THESE PEOPLE,
PEOPLE INSIDE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAVE BEEN TELLING ME THESE
ARE EXPLOITATIVE TACTICS.
>> EXPLAIN THIS IN DETAIL.
>> SO WE FOUND THAT THERE WERE
TEXT MESSAGES GOING OUT, THIS HE
WOULD FIND SOMEBODY'S PHONE
NUMBER AND KNOW THAT THEY WERE A
REPUBLICAN DONOR.
SO IN THIS SORT OF WIN RED
ONLINE DONATING SYSTEM YOUR
PHONE NUMBERS, YOUR CREDIT CARD
IS ALL SAVED.
SO THEY WOULD SEND YOU A TEXT
MESSAGE AND SAY A PROVOCATIVE
POLITICAL QUESTION, DO YOU THINK
JOE BIDEN SHOULD RESIGN?
WOULD YOU VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP
FOR A THIRD TIME?
REPLY YES TO DONATE $25.
AND THAT'S THE ENTIRETY OF THE
TEXT.
SHOWS UP FROM A 1-855 NUMBER.
IF YOU WRITE BACK YES, IF YOU
ARE A REPUBLICAN AND, AGAIN, A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE GETTING THESE
MESSAGES ARE OLDER PEOPLE, YOU
WRITE BACK YES YOU GET A $25
DONATION PROCESSED IMMEDIATELY
WITHOUT A LINK TO CLICK TO FIND
OUT WHERE THE TEXT WAS COMING
FROM TO THE NATIONAL REPUBLICAN
SENATORIAL COMMITTEE AND THIS
PRACTICE WAS ACTUALLY BLOCKED BY
WIN RED WHICH IS STORING THIS
CREDIT CARD INFORMATION.
THEY DIDN'T PROVIDE ANY COMMENT
TO ME.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE WOULDN'T
EVEN COMMENT OR DEFEND THE
TACTICS THEY WERE USING.
THEY ARE NO LONGER BEING ABLE TO
DO THIS BUT THEY DID THIS BY
SOME ESTIMATES TENS OF MILLIONS
OF THESE MESSAGES WENT OUT TO
AMERICANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> SAND THERE IS A METRIC FOR
HOW MUCH THIS HAS UPSET SOME
PEOPLE AND THAT IS --
>> THAT'S HOW MUCH YOU HAVE TO
REFUND IN MONEY.
IF PEOPLE ASK FOR THEIR MONEY
BACK IT USUALLY MEANS THEY'RE
UNHAPPY.
THE VOLUME OF REFUNDS THAT THE
SENATE REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE IS
GIVING, IT'S QUADRUPLE WHAT IT
WAS IN THE PREVIOUS CYCLE AND
IT'S FAR, FAR HIGHER THAN THE
DEMOCRATIC SENATE COMMITTEE'S
REFUND RATE.
>> NOT ONLY DO YOU NOT GET TO
KEEP THE MONEY, YOU UPSET THE
VERY PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET TO SUPPORT YOU.
>> YEAH, SO YOU LOOK AT THAT BIG
HAUL, WE BROUGHT IN MORE MONEY
THAN EVER BUT WE HAD TO REFUND
MORE THAN EVER.
>> RICK SCOTT THE SENATOR FROM
FLORIDA HAS RUN THIS COMMITTEE,
MITCH McCONNELL IS THE SENATE
MINORITY LEADER WHO WOULD BE
MAJORITY LEADER.
THERE'S BEEN TENSION BETWEEN
THESE TWO MEN ALREADY.
>> QUITE A BIT OF TENSION AND
PUBLIC TENSION WHICH IS REALLY
UNUSUAL BETWEEN TWO LEADERS OF
THE SAME PARTY IN THE SAME
CHAMBER.
THEY HAVE DISAGREEMENTS OVER
MONEY AND DISAGREEMENTS OVER
CANDIDATES.
MITCH McCONNELL FOR THE LAST
DECADE HAS SAID WE HAVE TO
INTERVENE IN THESE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES TO GET PEOPLE WHO
WON'T LOSE IN NOVEMBER AND RICK
SCOTT WHO THE PARTY OPPOSED WHEN
HE FIRST RAN FOR GOVERNOR IS
VERY MUCH AGAINST THAT.
SO WHAT YOU HAVE IS A SERIES OF
CANDIDATES WHO EMERGED FROM THE
PRIMARIES, MANY OF WHOM WERE
BACKED FROM DONALD TRUMP, MANY
OF WHOM WERE FIRST-TIME
CANDIDATES AND THE McCONNELL
TEAM ARE WORRIED THOSE
CANDIDATES WILL LOSE IN NOVEMBER
AND THE ONLY THING MITCH
McCONNELL CARES ABOUT IS WINNING
THE SENATE IN NOVEMBER.
>> JAY GOLDMACHER, A TERRIFIC
ARTICLE.
THANKS FOR SHARING YOUR
REPORTING WITH US THIS MORNING.